now more than ever we are exposed to a
plethora of ideas methods and
suggestions about life the Internet has
made it so we can consume and/or share a
seemingly unending amount of content on
the topic of living most effectively
however simultaneously this access to
information has also allowed the
consumer to realize just how conflicting
most ideas are in the West over the last
several decades or so not only has the
popularity of traditional religion
reduced as a result but for many the
increasing access to information has
revealed that the world is basically
without any discernible truth and most
ideas about how to live are inconclusive
and unreliable it is fair to speculate
that this could perhaps be a major
contributing factor to the modern
world's increasing levels of anxiety
cynicism and disillusion it's as if we
live in a constant debate over what is
true and good and every time we're about
to come to a decision someone says
something new or different and starts
the whole debate over dealing with and
choosing between conflicting ideas of
how to live has always been an issue for
the individual but in the modern world
where conflicting ideas are constantly
smacking us in the face now more than
ever we can often find ourselves failing
in our attempt to find footing in this
reality for every time a new idea
renders our previously withheld ideas
wrong or inferior we lose a little hope
and trusting any ideas at all no
religion philosophy science government
parent/teacher or self-help advice can
seemingly pieced together any truth or
answer to life that will rid us of our
uncertainty or hardship perhaps then it
is not a truth or answer that we must
seek to remove life's uncertainty and
hardship rather it is a template of
wisdom that we must experience life's
uncertainty and hardship through in an
attempt to find this we will look to the
movement of existentialism a movement
that started in the West during the 19th
century at the onset of a decreasing
popularity in traditional religions
specifically we will look to one of the
most renowned existential thinkers
jean-paul Sartre jean-paul Sartre was
born in 1905 in Paris France and is
considered to be one of the main
popularizers of existential thinking he
wrote numerous books that define much of
what existentialism is based on most
popularly being and
which describes the crux of existential
thought fro Sartre and the
existentialist life has no fundamental
meaning or truth beyond what is created
by our decisions and actions within it
the core of existential thought can be
summarized with the notion that as
humans our existence precedes our
essence in other words we have no
predetermined purpose and consequently
there is no specific way to live rather
both purpose and a way to live comes
only from living life in making choices
within it and for Sartre and
existentialist we are free to choose
what we do in a way it's as if we are
all given a slab of clay at birth and it
is up to us to decide what we mold it
into however Sartre points out that as
we grow older we become more and more
influenced by those around us and we
second-guess what we have started
molding and begin to copy what others
have already made an attempt to ensure
that we are making something good or
right however for Sartre there is no
right or wrong way to mold the clay
rather there are endless ways all
equally absurd all equally meaningless
and all equally worthy of molding to the
individual molding it this freedom to
mold life any way we wish coupled with a
deep desire for wanting to mold it as
best we possibly can is what brings on
such high levels of anxiety in life man
is condemned to be free because once
thrown into the world he is responsible
for everything he does
Sartre writes in other words we lack any
ability to know if our choices are good
or bad or right or wrong because for
whatever reason our human condition does
not permit us to we can never really
know if what we choose to make of our
life is what's best for us nor can
anyone else know yet we still must live
our life and make decisions within it
this premise is revealed very clearly
under the spotlight of the internet for
the widespread access to information
reveals very little beyond contradiction
we are now in an age where we find
ourselves with seemingly endless
information and potential solutions to
dealing with life yet increasing
anxieties depressions and confusions
existentialism would suggest that this
is because there are no timeless
definitive answers to human life that
apply to everyone we can't make any
choice knowing for sure if it will or
won't be what's best for us and so we
should not look for or expect any
ultimate answers that will
this doesn't mean that we should not
engage in consume consider or share
ideas research and philosophies about
life but it is to say that we should be
skeptical in our considerations in
mitigate our expectations accordingly in
many ways ideas for how to live are just
as much art and entertainment as they
are prescriptions for how to live no
matter how wise a piece of advice may
seem there is nothing to suggest that
anyone else can form a better idea for
how to live than one's own self so what
do we do if there's no accessible truth
or ultimate way to live how do we live
if no one could tell us or provide us
with a clear way existentialism suggests
one primary template of wisdom to deal
with this uncertainty of life that we
are left with for the existentialist
there is a constantly changing state of
existence though you must flow with
accepting the absurdity and
meaninglessness of it all and
transmuting the chaos of life into our
own unique experience and personal
meaning man
Sartre writes can will nothing unless he
has first understood that he must count
on no one but himself that he is alone
abandoned on earth in the midst of his
infinite responsibilities without help
with no other aim than the one he sets
himself with no other destiny than the
one he forges for himself on this earth
it is the truth that we deemed for
ourselves and carry out experientially
through our actions that defines what's
true for us for the truth of how to live
is relative in the modern information
age a great many of us feel further and
further disconnected we seek a truth
that will bring us in and resolve our
confusion and alienation when we don't
find it many of us begin to feel as
though something is wrong and that we
don't belong and perhaps that's because
we don't because no one does early on in
life we are given the idea that there is
really only a couple ways to live on
these predetermined paths we are told
that there is an ultimate goal of
perfection truth and happiness that we
are striving towards however perhaps it
is more likely that there are endless
ways of living ways that we each have to
determine for ourselves based on
ourselves and that none of what we do
will equate to any sort of ultimate
shared truth or meaning but rather a
sense of personal meaning and self
fulfillment when one realizes and
accepts that there are no fundamental
rules or truths in the world of human
existence the individual becomes
self-aware of their freedom and realizes
that they don't
to do anything specific in life we
realize that we don't have to follow or
agree with any of what we've been given
we can choose otherwise we don't have to
meet the standards of anyone else's
ideas for how to live be it our parents
friends teachers religions or cultures
the pressure and anxiousness of
constantly searching for the right way
to live can be alleviated and instead we
can look inwards consider how we wish to
experience life and work to mold
ourselves and choices accordingly we can
use our uniquely assembled self to
fulfill a uniquely assembled life
realizing our full potential
accepting the uncertainties and making
the endurance of existence personally
worth it
you